تقول زميلتك الجمهورية السناتور ليزا
موركوفسكي من ألاسكا إنه
يجب على الرئيس ترامب الاستقالة
قالت أه اقتباس أنه تسبب في أضرار كافية ،
هل توافق ، نعم أفعل ،
أعتقد أنه في هذه المرحلة قبل أيام قليلة فقط ،
إنه أفضل طريق للمضي قدمًا هو أفضل
طريقة
للحصول على  هذا الشخص في مرآة الرؤية الخلفية
بالنسبة لنا
يمكن أن يحدث على الفور ، لست
متفائلًا بأن ذلك سيحدث ،
لكنني أعتقد أن هذا سيكون أفضل
طريقة للمضي قدمًا
في إجراءات الإقالة
هذا الأسبوع ، قال السناتور الجمهوري بن ساسي
إن اقتباس الرئيس تجاهله
قسم المنصب أنه سينظر في
مواد العزل ،
هل تعتقد أنه يجب
عزل الرئيس ، هل ستصوت على عزله
من منصبه ،
لذلك أعتقد أن الرئيس قد ارتكب
جرائم تستوجب العزل أه
هناك القليل من الشك في ذهني حول هذا
لا أعرف  كمسألة عملية أنه من
الممكن في الواقع إجراء
عزل
في العدد في الأيام القليلة
المتبقية ،
فمن المحتمل أنه إذا  المنزل يمر
بمقالات المساءلة التي لن نحصل
عليها حتى
لا أعرف الثلاثاء أو الأربعاء ، نحن
حرفيًا أقل من أسبوع واحد للذهاب في
هذه المرحلة ،
كما أنني لست واضحًا على الإطلاق أنه من
المسموح دستوريًا عزل
شخص ما بعد  لقد تركوا مناصبهم ،
لذلك قد لا يكون هناك طريق عزل قابل للتطبيق
في هذه المرحلة ،
لكن بالتأكيد يمكنه الاستقالة
وستكون هذه نتيجة جيدة جدًا